22 we're into integers now put an
appropriate scale on the given number
line so we're expecting something like
that mark the following integers so you
can see and we did examples on this you
can see there's big marks there which
clearly show on the number line not
above not below not floating around on
the number line where the numbers hard
excuse me
only works to the city so she parked a
level negative five which is like a
basement level and then she goes all the
way up to 31 so you needed to find the
difference between those right if you
wanted to I noticed some people drew a
diagram so there's like a building and
there is you know at level 31 and she is
one two three four five below ground
right so she's got to go all the way up
those 31 and she also has to go up those
five and that's where the 36 number came
from okay
all right we leave the operations if you
set equals we that was wrong that equals
is not an operation
it's just say these two things are equal
to one another 25 read the question
really carefully I know lots of us got
tripped up on this and it is tricky
because you're rushing through yeah it
says which day which day not what was
the lower spirit of attempt are its
which day had the lowest bit of
temperature so that's why we wanted you
to answer Sunday and then Wednesday for
Part B okay
excuse me last question under integers
and I'll just let you have a look at
that working there I hope it's a
reasonably clear and you can see this
last question if you're wondering are
where where were the two marks most
people will approach that like this
you multiply a cross on the top which
gives you negative 32 and then you
multiply across I'm sorry you subtract
these on the bottom which gives you two
but that gives you a fraction you could
simplify right so that's where that
second mark was from okay fractions
where the tail end which of the
following numbers is the largest so you
can see it's and we're see we're
expecting you to maybe just do a
multiplication okay half of 100 that's
gonna be 50 a quarter of 200 that's also
50 and you can go on and on and
and you'll find out see is the largest
one draw a picture to show two-thirds of
half shaded so there are lots of ways to
get this one right and I see lots of
answers around that are different to
this one which got a tick can you see
the way it was approached I would have
thought about it as okay just look at
two-thirds of a half let's get a half
first right so this left-hand side of my
rectangle is half of the record and then
subsequent to that we said well okay if
I break it up two thirds this is two of
them right so that's the way that it was
drawn but you could draw it in a whole
bunch of different ways using two of the
numbers I don't know why this is across
two pages sorry about that what a
fraction that's close to one but less
than one so you've got lots of different
options but sorry you've got really try
to get as close as possible you like the
bigger stuff as possible if you had 1/2
or 3/4 or those kinds of things there's
going to be a bigger gap between you and
wanted okay bill went on a walk in an
Australian National Park he drew this
graph and this is about fractions again
showing the proportions so on the last
page I think it is 2/5 is the fraction
of the birds that were rose ellas
because you can see if you do if you had
a ruler with you you could measure each
of these sections out then you could
find out how much of it was there as a
proportion of the whole thing hi now
this one was quite sticky the earth was
2/3 how do we work out that this is 2/3
this time I am gonna ask who wants to
who got this question right and want to
explain how they went about it Daniel
okay sure
so for example we might say okay there's
going to be a triangle that can fit
there that's the same size I might make
this a bit bigger I could do the same
thing over here the same thing over here
and I raise your head if you had
something like that yeah excellent okay
fantastic
from there you can see oh look I've got
six triangles in the hexagon but the
whole being triangle
as night triangles right so if you have
6/9 that converted to 2/3